aniche années qu'on dit dans le fond
c'est le petit égard est souvent
un poisson qui utilisez beaucoup par les
premières nations ça vous dit quelque
chose qui est très très faim ou est-ce
que la fraîcheur est importante
c'est aussi fabuleux l'histoire de la
ouananiche au lac-saint-jean que peut
l'être l'histoire du charbon à l'échelle
du québec
[Musique]
c'est un véritable symbole du lac saint
jean la ouananiche ce saumon est enfermé
dans ses eaux douces depuis la fin de
l'ère glaciaire il est très prisé des
touristes pêcheurs comme geneviève et
les eaux venues de québec avec l'espoir
de goûter à ce poisson unique
les deux belles journées caen a passé
aussi qu'ils étaient nos premières l'une
avec le coup beaucoup de vagues du vin
beaucoup d'émotion puis aujourd'hui plus
calmes et une pêche plus difficile mais
patience l'humilité
l'histoire de la ouananiche là c'est une
histoire fabuleuse marque archers dirige
la corporation lactivité pêche au lac
saint jean un organisme qui veille à la
préservation de la ressource
dans les années 1880 il ya un américain
du nom de la jeune scène bieber qui
était dans l'industrie du chemin de fer
aux états unis qui a découvert la pêche
à la ouananiche au lac saint jean et la
réaliser tout le potentiel halieutique
et touristique de ce poisson et du lac
saint jean il s'est empressé d'acheter
et où les droits exclusifs de pêche
sportive au lac saint jean et dans les
tributaires du lac et il ya développer
une véritable industrie
touristique de la pêche à la ouananiche
il y avait construit avant berval un
immense hôtel qui à l'époque était un
des plus gros hôtel à l'échelle du
canada la clientèle sept corps est mal
toute la noblesse nord-américaines et
européennes
on voit par exemple le tsar de russie
l'empereur du japon
seuil est venue des politiciens des
artistes de partout à travers le monde
sans eau à sbi main le lac saint jean ne
serait peut-être pas ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui
les gens réalisent pas ce poisson alors
est le déclencheur de tout
l'industrialisation de la région parce
que les fondateurs des alumineries et
compagnie quand ils sont venus ici son
lycée pour la paix qu il connaissait pas
le potentiel hydroélectrique
pas du tout ils y ont vu son enfant
apparaît ici et là yosi aux boys il ya
de l'argent à faire ici
[Musique]
comme pour les viandes sauvages et le
saumon de rivière la commercialisation
de la ouananiche est interdite mais si
vous avez la chance d'empêcher une sa
chair moins grave que le saumon
d'élevage mérite toute votre attention
si tu veux être dans l'air du temps
c'est ce que le cruel
unilatérale est vraiment quelque chose
qui est intéressant peut-être différente
diane tremblay et chef et consultant en
restauration
mi cuit à l'unilatérale donc là on a
trois textures différentes dans une même
boucher ce qui peut être super agréable
au point de vue des textures sous la
langue
le cru et le cuit puis le croustillant
sur la peau fille qui est très très
croustillant et celui là je les
accompagne et le d'un petit peu de
coriandre et de persil un accompagnement
classique avec le poisson
c'est un poisson qui est plus gras même
s'il fait partie des poissons gras mais
beaucoup moins gras que les saumons pour
apprécier la finesse de cette chaire
diane propose en carpaccio on le tout
simplement accompagner un peu de sel un
peu de poids bien sûr accompagné avec
une salade de fenouil et de bette à
carde qui était l arroser le citron de
lyme ensuite le seul de sirop d'érable
et de basilic c'est une des choses qu'on
retrouve généralement dans un tartare
sauf que dans cette artère bouchée en
bouche et c'est la même chose tandis que
en carpaccio c'est plus rapide et les
saveurs peuvent évoluer selon ce que tu
veux dégustez de pouvoir manger la
ouananiche cru comme ça on le goûte
vraiment qu'est ce que la ouananiche
brut
à moosch des hoyas communautés innues au
bord du piékouagami le nom original du
lac saint jean la pêche au filet est une
longue tradition
avec mon pagne et aux 85 ans moi et mes
enfants dont comprend le transfert
intergénérationnel décembre et
l'objectif c'est qu'on commence à la
pêche avec eux j'ai commencé à démontrer
comment préparer le filet c'est à dire
dans le fond comment organiser
ni plus ni moins cette pêche d'autres
une aubaine prix d'embarcations d'alu et
tendre vers le large et là on est en
grès du nom à ce que ça vaut guépard
l'eau tout simplement pas filoche et la
roche dans le fond ou à tuer certains se
soient bien tendu en distance
c'était la pratique la pêche
traditionnelle au filet donc ça
permettait de se nourrir
souvent on va dénaturer la saveur du
poisson parce que l'objectif en premier
lancer vraiment de goûter ce qu'on a
récolté si vous ne jamais manger mon
aniche il faudra manger comme elle vient
on trouve un bois embraye sondés mais
dans le feu on tourne c'est un peu comme
un poêlon de la bresse donc
nécessairement vol tourne et puis on va
regarder
le poisson cuir puis loeb à ce moment-là
vous goûtez la charge
[Musique]
ça coûte le sien sans doute quelque
chose que vous avez jamais goûté
probablement c'est pas le saumon qu'on
connaît vous connaissez de course au
monde c'est son cousin d'enfants mais
qui reste est pris lui dans le bassin où
on est aujourd'hui
[Musique]